i want us to think about where we've
been in complex numbers so far we've
covered a lot of ground and yet at the
same time
we've also been doing like fairly
fundamental things for example
um it was difficult enough to like
understand
you know what is i what's our definition
for that
so we introduced it as what what is what
does it mean
we yeah we introduced it sort of as the
square root of negative one
right it's this way of dealing with this
weirdo exotic
c strange kind of number but also
importantly
connecting it with the other number
system that we're used to so these
imaginary numbers of course
when you are when you combine them with
the real numbers that's why we get
complex numbers right so we're familiar
with this idea but then as soon as we
opened up this kind of can of worms
right
even some of the simplest things that
we've been doing for years and years
actually we noticed in this world are
kind of challenging
right we could add and we could subtract
these numbers
fairly straightforwardly that arithmetic
was not dramatically different
but as soon as we got to like
multiplication we started to realize
oh okay we have to think carefully about
this right some of the multiplication
ends up being very messy
that's part of why we introduced polar
form for example if you had
two complex numbers right here's one
and i'm going to write it in polar form
for us and here's another
and so i'm giving you this all in terms
of
pronumerals rather than giving you an
actual r or
actual alpha because we can generalize
from here right if i took these two
and i multiply them this is something we
just recently developed right
what do we do with these things out the
front the moduli what happens to those
we multiply them right so we get r1 r2
and then what happens to the
arguments the angles in here when we
multiply these complex numbers
yeah we add them isn't that convenient
we multiply the moduli
we add the arguments so we would get in
this case cos
of alpha plus beta and then plus
i sine of alpha plus beta so you're like
something as simple as just
multiplication leads you to
complexity like this complexity so i did
there and then division right just to
divide stuff we had to introduce this
idea of conjugates
all that kind of thing okay and this is
just your basic operations
one of the things we've done though is
we haven't gone any further than these
operations really we've we've done all
of these with
rectangular forms standard form
cartesian form we've also done them with
uh polar or mod arc form but the uh the
territory we have not
dared to go into yet is the natural sort
of extension of this right
addition is where we start with counting
numbers and subtraction is just the
reverse
of that multiplication we start thinking
about as repeated addition
that's what three times five means right
like you add up five
three times and we think of division as
the reverse
of multiplication well just like we
think of multiplication as repeated
addition
what's that shorthand we use for when
you repeat
multiplication what is that if i said to
you like
5 times 5 times 5 we would say yeah
exponents
indices powers that's what we would say
right so
if we were to write this down to say
something like you know x to the power
of
n the fancy name for this this is our
heading by the way
is exponentiation
now we have not dared to go here because
as soon as you start to think about what
this means in this world
you run into some massive problems right
let's think about this
just in the um just in the real number
world right um what was the example i
gave you five times five times five okay
so
five cubed we're pretty happy to come up
with an idea of what this means
on the basis of what we've just done
here right you're like oh
i have a definition for that that just
uh sits very comfortably in something
you could give to like
oh i don't know like a seven-year-old
child could understand this idea you
just give them a cue
right hence this right i could of course
extend it and do something like that
there'd be no problems
just like just do it more okay we can
sort of go
further in this idea by saying well if
that's a positive index
what do we mean by a negative index
like we actually know what this means
what how would you describe 5 to the
power of negative 2
because you're not multiplying any more
ie yeah what do you think
yeah the reciprocal of the positive
index okay the reciprocal of the
positive index so if i had five squared
this would be the reciprocal of that
but think about why that must make sense
like the reciprocal
essentially you're saying i'm no longer
in multiplication land i'm in
division land right that makes sense
because you're doing the opposite of
multiplication
we can even go further and say sure
you've got natural numbers you've got
integers we can even handle rational
numbers right we have a definition for 5
to the power of a half what is it how
would we normally write it
square root of 5 right because 5 to the
power of a half
times 5 to the power of a half just
using your index laws that should be 5
to the power of
1 because same base so you add the
indices so you can see how we're kind of
extending through think back to like
less than one in complex numbers right
these different families of numbers
but then it starts to get real confusing
right
when we said counting numbers integers
uh sorry natural numbers integers
rational numbers i think the next step
was irrational numbers
wasn't it now can you come up with an
intuitive way to explain what on earth
that means
this starts to become trickier right
you're like
what am i going to do with this okay now
we can come up with ways to understand
what's going on because
thankfully these kinds of things here
they they sort of go along a smooth
curve
right if i were to graph 5 to the power
of whatever you want
5 to the power of x we know exactly what
that curve looks like right
that's just a stock standard exponential
curve okay
so just like on the number line we can
just find anywhere on there that we like
we can say oh 5 to the 30 that's
somewhere over here ridiculous massive
number
5 to the power of negative 2 it's
somewhere over here 5 to the power of a
half if i said if i've got some scale on
here i just say oh we'll go halfway
right and root 2 it's like oh that's
just another number on here it's about
1.4
so i don't know what it means exactly
but i can still
find a value that makes sense
for that right and that's what your
calculator does hands you back that
value
you can see where this is going though
can't you right we're already starting
to push the boundaries of our intuition
what on earth would something
like that mean where does that even go
okay now we already know we're going to
be pushing
the envelopes or our intuition here um
because all of this
everything that you just saw me sort of
put up on this graph it's all real
numbers
100 real weird but real
right so where does this go this is the
question we're going to try
and settle for today and believe it or
not it's going to settle on some of the
stuff that we did
in our starters today so here's what i'd
like you to do
make a little subheading for me
and i'm going to ask you to make this
subheading informal
proof which is kind of um
it's kind of a contradicting in terms
but we'll run with it okay what i'm
going to try and do for you is develop
an idea for what
exponentiation indices in imaginary
terms are i want to try and give you a
feel
for what that is what i'm going to do is
i'm going to kind of do an informal
quick way today i hope you leave the end
of this thinking okay that kind of makes
sense
but i want to know more i'm kind of i
would like to get more
like a stronger foundation underneath
this but i think it'll be enough for you
to actually start working with the
results that we get from this
okay so this is going to be the question
i sort of want to answer
to get to that let's have a think about
something that i know is going to sound
a bit harder but believe it or not
actually gives us tools or gives us
access to tools that will be more
helpful instead of raising
a number like 5 to the power of i you
can see how i thought about this
actually in terms of um just functions
right once you have a picture like this
all of this kind of falls into place
does that make sense even even weirdos
like this
okay so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to put instead of a number in here
i'm going to put an
entire exponential function okay now of
all the exponential functions
that we know about strangely enough the
easiest one to deal with is this guy
okay now what's e who's encountered this
number before
you've seen it before right even if you
haven't done heaps of work with it
it's a number that's roughly equal to
it's about two point seven two point
seven one eight
two eight one eight two and it just
keeps going okay
now this number has some really
important properties which we'll come to
in a second so this is what we're going
to deal with i want to try and
understand this
okay now we know
complex numbers right they have a real
part and they have an imaginary part
real part imaginary part that's kind of
the foundation we started with
now this guy here is not a complex
number it's a complex
function right it's a whole different
kind of object but it's reasonable to
assume
that a complex number has a real and
imaginary part
a complex function also ought to have a
real
and imaginary part does that make sense
there's going to be two pieces so how do
i write that
the way i'm going to show that is that
there will be a real part
and an imaginary part like so
but because the thing on this left-hand
side is a function
these two things here are also going to
be functions does that make sense like
it can change depending on what value of
x i put in there okay
so rather than writing my um my bits as
a and b
i should put this i out the front sorry
about that riley calling just a and b
numbers i'm going to call them a
of x that's a function do you see that
this is our function notation from
earlier in the year
i don't know what this thing is but it's
a thing that changes when i input x
we'll find out what it is in a second
same deal for this guy right the
imaginary part
i don't know what it is but it'll also
be a function of some
description okay with that
this looks like it's getting worse not
better this is what happens you know
when you've um if you ever get to a
point you're like i should clean up my
room i'm doing some cleaning
at the moment and things always look
worse before they get better right
you're like
things that like they were all in piles
but at least they were in like you know
together
and then at a certain point everything
is just on the floor everywhere right
have you gotten to this point
i hope at least once in your life you
have otherwise you're like maybe your
cat's underneath that pile anyway
this looks worse than what we started
with you're like five the eye looks so
nice and neat
but the reason why i chose this is
because like i said it gives us access
to some tools
here's what i'm going to do on the next
line everything here you can see on the
left
and the right hand side i'm going to
differentiate it
everything you can see on the left and
on the right i'm going to
differentiate it so let's just write
what that looks like right if i
differentiate
the left hand side this thing here uh
index laws help me out with this right
when you've got something raised to a
power raised to another power what do
you do with those indices again
you multiply them so i'm just going to
write that like so is that all right
like i haven't done anything to it i've
just sort of tied it up this side and
more brackets around okay
okay what do i get on the right hand
side um this is weird because
a of x is some function b of x is some
function i don't even know what they are
but thankfully i have notation for
talking about the derivatives of these
even when i don't know what they
actually are equal to if a of x is a
function what would i write its
derivative as
a dash is normally the way i would do it
so that's me
differentiating that bit right and then
i have to kind of do the same thing over
here this is
b dash do you agree so i'm just going to
write that b dash
how does that look to you so far is that
okay like so far
i know this looks um a little bit weird
and unusual but hopefully we can agree
it's true
where can i go with this all right i
need a bit more space
i want us to think about a trick that
we've been using in
complex numbers which i think we did
either in lesson two or less than three
way back at the start
which is to say if you've got a left
hand side and right hand side
and they both have real bits and
imaginary bits and they're they're
equivalent to each other right
i should be able to compare the real
bits on each side
and the imaginary bits on each side do
you remember that and they should be
equal right we've actually done this
several times we would say
equating the real and imaginary parts
that's what we want to do
but at the moment i'm like what what is
in here right what are the real and
imaginary parts
in this well we should be able to work
it out because unlike over here where
i'm like
a and b who knows what they are we
actually can do some stuff with this
because
of this function now i know we haven't
quite got to it yet but the reason why i
chose
e to the power of x is because it has
and i'll just write it over here in
different color
it has this special relationship with
differentiation
right the exponential curve like this
right
derivatives tell you about gradient
remember that right so you have a look
at this exponential curve
doesn't the gradient of this curve think
about how you would describe it
the gradient of this curve is always
positive and the
the bigger your value of x the steeper
the gradient is do you agree with that
the bigger the gradient is in other
words the gradient of this exponential
curve
sounds a whole lot like the exponential
curve itself doesn't it right you see
this
curve is always positive and the further
you go to the right the bigger it gets
so this curve here this function is the
special one
such that its derivative is exactly
equal
to itself now say that again right this
is the special function
whose derivative is exactly itself and
that is immensely useful
to try and work out this guy let's do it
now i'm differentiating
e to the power of not just x but i x so
think back to your starter questions i
just rubbed it off but you should have
it there in your book right
what was the first question i gave you
what were you differentiating
x squared plus one to the power of five
right
so which um which rule did you use to
help you differentiate that
that's the chain rule right because
you're like i don't have time to raise
this to the power of five and expand
that out and i don't need to
you have a function of a function and
that's exactly what you have here
you see this you've got a function
here e to the power of something but
it's e to the power of
another function in there so i want you
to look at how you did
your chain rule on question one today
you had two steps didn't you
you had to differentiate the inside bit
and then you differentiate the outside
bit okay let's do those two pieces
here's the inside bit i x
we know i's weird but it's just a number
what's the derivative of
i x it's just i right if you
differentiate like 5x you just get 5.
so i'm going to write i that's that's it
that's the derivative of the inside bit
okay now i have to take care of the
outside right
the outside is e to the power of some
stuff but
we've just sort of talked about the fact
that this is the weird function that
when you differentiate it you just hand
back
itself so if this is the inside here
comes
the derivative of the outside does that
make sense i know this is kind of weird
territory
but you just differentiated this weird
bizarre looking function
that's it that was us using the chain
rule are you okay so far